longtemps perçu comme des créatures
étranges les drag queens sont devenus en
quelques amis au phénomène grand public
en juillet ça fait 31 ans que j'exerce
ce métier là et oui j'ai vu les vols
j'ai vu plusieurs évolutions parce que
ça bouge beaucoup
maintenant on fait des spectacles
n'importe où dans une course une famille
à laval en beauce au saguenay ça partout
on est partout
le succès de l'émission l'opposera grèce
une télé réalité américaine qui en est à
sa 11e saison a contribué à la
démocratisation de ce phénomène
au début c'était dans la communauté lgbt
roparun c'est comme une partie du
canadien au centre bell les bat son
plein les gens hurlent c'est une
euphorie totale les gens ont leurs drag
queen préféré mais maintenant on voit
que ça s'étend à un très large public
d'adolescents st beaucoup de gens un
terreau sexuelle qui vont venir voir
cette soirée nord que ce soit pour
raconter des histoires aux enfants dans
les bars ou encore des drag queens
atteintes de trisomie 21
elles sont sur tous les fronts et le
public est au rendez vous
c'est un très bon divertissement c'est
les bons shows la ville c'est des vrais
artistes
moi je suffoque mon garçon qui est une
drag queen damon la slade bien j'ai
toujours supporté les drag queen tout
longue carrière
j'adore ça vous tombe
c'est très intéressant parce que faut
s'ouvrir les yeux sur le fait que des
gens et non pas deux genres et je
trouvais intéressant de pouvoir vivre un
petit peu dit moment avec vous il existe
une multitude de styles de dracul leur
point commun des looks colorés et du nom
accrocheur damon lac mirage the band is
a light show via la vente d'un homme
pour certains c'est devenu un vrai
métier
c'est sûr qu'un petit petit réseau
d'artistes qui réussissent à vivre de
leur art comme dans n'importe quelle
discipline au québec d'ailleurs je suis
un des chanceux qui qui peut vivre de ça
mais je peux dire aussi que j'ai créé ma
chance
jack superstar qui met en vedette les
participants de l'émission gros pôles de
la grèce et pour les plus grands fans
il sera même possible de les rencontrer
pour une séance d'autographes à conduire
des frais de débourser des 300 dollars
que coûte le bien vieilli sinaï
direction chartier radio canada montréal